we're joined now
uh by tulip sadiq she's the shadow
treasury minister thank you very much
for being with us um just before we get
on to that um i just wanted to get your
view on what oliver dowden was just
saying at the end of the interview about
his view that a woke ideology is
effectively corrosive and that we should
be proud of this country's history
what's your take on that well i thought
the quote that you stated from him at
the start was ridiculous and i think he
should have explained it better but i
can see why he decided not to like of
course i agree with the fact that we
shouldn't go and rip down statues but
there is real anger there because some
of the statues and some of the history
relates to a very dark past for us let's
say slave masters or people who feel
like we haven't acknowledged what role
people had to play in sacrificing so i
think name changes after a consultation
with community makes sense but it's also
about it's not just about name calling
it's also about the fact that people
feel their voices haven't been heard
their points of view haven't been heard
i think we have to be quite respectful
of the debate of course i don't want
people to be violent when it comes to it
i also think oliver doubter needs to
think very carefully about the fact that
for years and years history was taught
in a way that airbrushed a lot of the
atrocities that took place and that a
lot of people felt
that their part of history hadn't been
acknowledged so for example locally
beckford primary school have just
changed their name to west hampstead
primary school and all the children know
why they know why the history of the
school wasn't appropriate while the name
wasn't appropriate it wasn't done in a
way where why was that then to people
who may not
because it was it was someone associated
with the slave trade and they didn't
want to do that in a community like ours
which is very diverse people felt that
they wanted to be named in the local
area as well as hampshire and not
referred to a name that was put in the
past but i do find and some of the
attitude around this has become quite
unhelpful and corrosive as well and not
taking in other people's points of view
okay or interesting to hear both sides
of the debate there uh today labour
wants to focus on the cost of living uh
you're calling for an emergency budget
just to explain what the idea of that is
so sophie as you said i am a shadow
treasury minister but i'm also a
constituency mp and i've been taken
aback and frankly speaking along by the
number of people coming to my advice
surgeries talking about the fact that
they can't afford the basic food that
they want to buy for their children i
have women coming to my surgery on
friday saying i'm dreading the weekend
because i can't feed my children they
can't afford to put on the heating
things are really bad they can't meet
let alone affording petrol they
literally can't buy basic food items and
clothes for their children so we're very
worried we're very worried that this
national insurance hike is going to hit
people's pay packets this week we're
very worried about the fact that there
weren't enough measures mentioned in the
spring statement on the 23rd of march to
meet some of the challenge of the cost
of living crisis that's taking place
right now so from the labour party we've
said that we want to put forward an
emergency budget which we want the
chancellor to adopt okay i just want to
read you the first line of the press
release this was sent by labour
to journalists about the emergency
budget idea following another week of
the conservatives focusing on their
internal strife labour's calling the
government to introduce an emergency
budget
i mean that's a bit rich isn't it i mean
it was labour who's been focusing on
party gay isn't it i mean that's what
kierst dahmer asked about prime
minister's questions it was labor who
put down the motion for npc to vote on
whether the pm misled the house i mean
i'm not saying i'm not getting into
debate about whether it's right or wrong
to focus on party gate but i'm just
saying you can't exactly accuse the
conservatives as being the ones that's
focusing on this can you the prime
minister who holds the highest office in
our country he was in charge of looking
after the country when the coronavirus
hit broke the rules and lied to
parliament i understand why you're
focusing on it but i'm just saying that
you have to admit that you're focusing
on it don't you rather than saying oh
it's the conservatives who've been
destroyed i don't think it's either or i
think you can talk about partygate and i
think we're going to discuss that later
on but i just want to go on to why we
think the emergency budget is so
important at this point in time sophie
the things we're calling for in the
emergency budget for start is the
windfall tax which i'm sure you've heard
about we're saying that we should tax
oil and gas producers profits and we
should make sure that we take around 600
pounds of energy labor
frequently talking about the
we've talked about businesses as well so
i would challenge any mp oliver dalton
was just here but any mp that you speak
to to take a walk in their constituency
and speak to local businesses and ask
them if they're struggling or not so
we're saying that we have to give a tax
break to businesses especially to smes
is this is this an admission
that perhaps voters actually want labour
to move on from focusing on party gate
and to talk about the cost of living
well of course you want to talk of the
about the cost of living crisis of
course we do because it's such a real
threat to people and i've mentioned the
world full tax i've mentioned the fact
that we have to focus on giving tax
breaks to businesses especially smes and
we're talking about that at the moment
i've talked about the fact that we've
got to make sure we halt the national
insurance rise that's happening at the
moment also the fraud which i should
really mention national crime agency
we've asked them to look into the fact
that there's 11.8
billion pounds worth of fraud that
happened during the covet schemes and no
one's in the government seems to be
talking about that 11.8 billion pounds
is not an insignificant figure when it
comes to fraud and crime why weren't the
basic facts in check why weren't they
checking the fact that duplicate loan
forms had been given in so we've got to
look at that and the final thing we're
asking for is that we have to have a
rapid program a proper program to look
into how we insulate homes so that we
can actually take money off people's
energy bills okay now you've been very
involved in the campaign to free nazim
zagari at rackley if you're a
constituent who is of course imprisoned
in iran she's now safely back playing
with her family that i'm sure we're all
extremely thankful for now the foreign
affairs select committee have said that
they want to have an investigation
inquiry
into how the government handled uh this
now they
they announced this at the beginning of
the april um but today's on the 24th of
april is there any sign about when
that's actually going to get going so
the minute nazanin came home um richard
radcliffe her husband and i said there
has to be an inquiry into why this
didn't happen sooner she was away for
six years and we know for a fact there
was a few missed opportunities when the
government could have brought her back
and they didn't so i asked tom taking
the heart and i wrote him and said look
you've got to conduct an inquiry into
this not just because of naznen but to
make sure it doesn't happen again in the
future and the general policy of hostage
shaking by iran and they wrote back a
few days later and said they were going
to conduct this inquiry i haven't heard
much about it but i do know that i won't
be inquired to go ahead to find out why
there were so many missed opportunities
about bringing nazine home to make sure
it doesn't happen again but also there's
a very important incident that happened
in 2013 where three british officials
came to the uk they were detained in
heathrow airport and put in a detention
center and they actually came apparently
to negotiate the repayment of this debt
and drug straw said to me he has never
got to the bottom of why this happened
and why they were arrested and detained
and why we never did anything about it
so are you worried that this inquiry
might be being kicked into the long
grass because obviously it could be
quite awkward for the government
couldn't it it could be potentially very
awkward for the government and it could
also um unearth some of the missed
opportunities and why we didn't bring
her back home earlier i mean six years
is a very long time i hope the inquiry
takes place i'll certainly be holding
the foreign fire select committee do you
get a sense that it's being kicked into
the long run i'm a bit worried i haven't
heard anything about it and i feel like
more should be made of course there's a
lot going on in politics and the cost of
living crisis that we've just been
talking about partygate but at the same
time i don't want to lose focus on it
and i think it's what nazi my
constituent deserves we've got the
french elections of course uh coming up
later on today i'll be uh heading to
paris uh after the show to present from
there
with the labour government if a labor
government i should say rather than the
labor government would a labor
government be comfortable
working with marine le pen who's a far
right leader
i should start off by saying i hope that
is a situation that doesn't arise
but if it does come i mean i suppose
what we have to do is do the best we can
as in the government worked with trump
when he was elected you probably know he
had some views that we didn't always
accept some of the views about muslims
especially weren't ones that we wanted
to take place i guess as a responsible
government you have to work with any
government i do hope though sophie can i
just say the result goes in a different
direction okay uh pretty clear what uh
you mean there uh right just finally i
just want to ask about this story in the
middle on sunday uh this is about uh
angela rayner i also speak to oliver
downton about ellie in the show in the
show but i think we can show the picture
there
uh this is uh the accusation that angela
rainer is using basic instinct ploy to
distract boris johnson at prime
minister's questions by which it feels
like she is just sitting across from him
in order to distract him
um
given the kind of allegations in the
sunday times today about the fact that
there are these alleged reports of
sexual harassment going into watchdog
what would you say about the culture in
westminster when it's with regards to
women mps
i feel like i can't even read and look
at this front page that's why i was
looking away because i think the story
is so disgraceful and i actually i'm
quite upset because i heard what oliver
dowden said and i think he should have
been stronger in condemning this at the
end of the day angela rainer is an mp
who got elected on merit to talk about
the fact that she's using her legs or
her posture to manipulate the prime
minister is ridiculous i'm really upset
about it i'm also very upset sophie
about these allegations that there's
more stories coming out of mps abusing
their position
for sexual favors or to manipulate stuff
and all the accusations that are coming
up i don't care which party the mps are
from if there has to be an independent
review there has to be an independent
panel that looks into this if they're
people from my party there should be a
zero tolerance to this if it's people
from the government it should be a zero
tolerance we've got to wait make
westminster more welcoming for female
mps but also staff members as well i
mean a question i regularly get when i
get to schools is is westminster very
abusive for women is that the kind of
rhetoric we want to be heard and would
you say that it is or not well you know
i'm caught between a rock and a hard
place because i don't want to put
determined in interesting women off
politics but the truth is that we've got
to tackle all these challenges that are
coming up but can i just make a point
about partygate because we didn't talk
about that one of my main worries is not
just that the prime minister and the
chancellor's taking their eye off the
cost of living crisis while they're
trying to save their own skin my other
worry is what kind of message does that
send out to the public that we are meant
to be the authority that makes
legislation people hate politicians
anyway and they're losing further faith
in us next time there's a pandemic or
something like this happens the public
won't listen because they made huge
sacrifices during the pandemic and the
prime minister are carried on and then
lie to parliament okay uh boris johnson
of course would say that he didn't line
to uh parliament important for me to put
that a point uh across but thank you
very much for your time today to
obviously good to talk